in this video we're going to be going
through the algebra 2 midterm exam
review for the first semester of algebra
2 so I put together 62 different types
of problems over 100 plus examples in
this video and in the description below
if you go down there I've got timestamps
that will take you directly to any
particular problem that you want to
focus on so let's get into this video
question number 1 it says write the
numbers in increasing order this is a
typical problem that you see on a
first-semester exam and basically what
the key is to this problem in my opinion
to make easier to convert these into
decimals this makes it easier for you to
compare them so what I'm going to do is
I'm just going to convert these into
decimals we know that pi is 3.14 so I'm
just going to put it right below it we
know that negative 4.7 is already a
decimal okay square root of 37 I'm going
to go to the calculator and get an
approximation for that one okay so that
looks like it's about six point one if
we round okay six point one and then 36
fifths again we can take 36 divided by
five and we've got seven point two so
here it says write the orders the
numbers in increasing order sometimes
it'll say decreasing order so increasing
order we want to go from the lowest to
the highest so you can see negative four
point seven is the lowest okay
so we'll put that first the next one as
you go along the number line remember
from negative to positive and zeros in
the middle right so the next smallest
one is going to be 3.14 but instead of
writing 3.14 you want to write pi okay
just like in the same form that they
gave it to you and then the next one
after that looks like it's going to be
six point one which is the square root
of 37
and then after that that's going to be
seven point two which in this case
they're giving it to us as a fraction 36
fifths so that's question number one now
what you might want to do is you go
through this video courses pause the
video okay see if you can do the problem
on your own first and then we can go
through together you might get more out
of it that way okay now example number
two here it says if you bike 20 miles
per hour what is your speed and feet per
second okay so this is a good question
here and basically what they're testing
us on in this problem is can we convert
from miles per hour to feet per sec
so let's see what we have here let's
start off with the 20 miles per 1 hour
per means divided by by the way and
we're going to convert that into feet
per second so let's see so for every
mile one mile is equal to 5,280 feet see
this way the miles cancel numerator and
denominator and we've got feet per hour
but we actually want feet per second now
we know that there's 3,600 seconds in
one hour
right so this way the hours cancel again
numerator and denominator and what we
have is feet per second or feet divided
by seconds which is what we want so what
we're gonna do now is I'm going to
multiply all the numerators together all
the denominators together and I'm gonna
divide okay and that's how we're gonna
get our answers so if we do that I'm
gonna go to the calculator 20 times
5,280 right ok and then I'm going to
divide that by 1 times 1 times 3600
which just comes out to 3600 and that
comes out to twenty nine point three
three I'm just going to round it to
twenty nine point three repeating feet
per second okay so you're with me so far
so let's go to number three now that
says evaluate this is a four part
question and what they're testing us on
in this question is you know do we know
the order of operations the PEMDAS
remember the please excuse my dear Aunt
Sally so what we have here is we got
negative three to the fourth but notice
that that's in parentheses we have to
take it as a group it's actually
negative 3 times negative 3 times
negative 3 times negative 3 you see four
times if we have four negatives
multiplied together that gives us what a
positive right so an even number of
negatives is positive so this is really
going to be positive 81 okay now the
second part negative 3 to the fourth a
lot of students will get confused on
this because they don't realize you have
to do the exponents here first
and then multiply by the negative second
so parentheses first exponents second
multiplication third so 3 to the fourth
is 81 then times the negative that gives
us negative 81 letter C here negative 3
to the third power again same thing 3
cubed is 27 3 times 3 times 3 so that's
negative 27 and then the last one you
can see we've got negative 3 cubed but
what's different about this problem is
we've got negative 3
three times right three times but when
you have a negative times a negative
times a negative an odd number of
negatives you get a negative so this is
going to work out to negative 27 okay so
good question order of operations number
four that says evaluate which means find
the value right of this expression here
when y equals negative three so all are
really telling us here is you know this
is just a typical substitution problem
we want to put negative three in
wherever we see Y now when you do these
substitution problems I recommend
putting it in parenthesis so it takes it
as a group okay so you take it as a
group or if you put it in your
calculator your calculator takes it as a
group okay otherwise you know you can
get the wrong answer if you do it in
without having the parentheses so let's
focus on the order of operations like we
did up here negative three squared is a
positive nine because you have two
negatives so this is really nine okay
and then over here we've got a negative
3 times a negative 3 which is a positive
9 see when you see - you can think of
that as a negative number so negative
times a negative is a positive and then
plus 2 now a negative 2 times 9 is
negative 18 ok and you can see that 9 +
2 is 11 so we have a negative 18 plus 11
which is a negative 7 and you got it ok
question number five says you're
starting a tutoring business it costs
you four hundred dollars in start-up
costs and you charge $60 per session
right a profit equation given the number
of tea sessions and then Part B says
calculate the profit after 30 sessions
ok this is a typical problem and what
they're testing us on here is slope
intercept form so remember slope
intercept form is the y equals MX plus B
form of a line and you can see what's
happening here is that the M is the
slope or the rate and in this case you
know this person is charging $60 per
session so 60 times the number of
sessions you know T sessions and then B
that's the y-intercept but that's in a
story problem it's the initial condition
or the starting amount in this case the
starting amount is that it's $400 so in
this case we're going to think of that
as a negative 400 because you know your
startup cost as a negative you haven't
made any profit so basically what we
have here is you have profit okay the
output is the number of tutoring
sessions times 60
- the $400 for the initial startup costs
so that's your equation there y equals
MX plus B Part B says calculate the
profit after 30 sessions so all we have
to do here is put 30 in place of T so if
we do that 60 times 30 is 1800 minus the
400 and you can see that's going to be
$1400 remember your units for word
problems right so let's go to number six
so it says solve these two equations
okay a and B so a lot of times students
freak out when they see all these
fractions they say oh I hate fractions
but what you can do is you can clear the
denominators okay this is a great
technique and what you do to clear
denominators you can think of any whole
number as a fraction by putting it over
one and then what you do is you look at
all the denominators and you say what's
the lowest common denominator meaning
what's the smallest number that 3
divides into 5 divides into and one
divides into it in this case you can see
that's going to be 15 they all go into
15 evenly so then what you do is you
multiply everything in the equation by
15 left and right sighs it keeps the
equation balanced and what happens is C
15 divided by 3 is 5 times 1 is gonna be
5 and that's X now if this is a little
bit confusing what you can do is right
next to the 1/3 put 15 over 1 and then
what you can do is you can cross reduce
like that the one in the 5 are right
next to each other so they're multiplied
together that's how I get the 5 X same
thing here or if you don't want to do
that you can just say 15 times 2 is 30
divided by 5 is 6 and then over here the
same thing 15 times 5 is 75 not only to
think about it is when you're
multiplying fractions you multiply the
numerators together in the denominators
together okay so continuing on we get
11x equals 75 divided both sides by 11
you can see that's going to be 75
elevenths and we got it okay let's go to
Part B now this one here what it's
testing us on is the distributive
property and here's where students go a
little bit off when they see this minus
sign okay the a little bit confused
about what to do do ice Tribute the 2
and then subtract or do i distribute
negative 2 what I like to do is just
think of whenever I see a minus sign I
like to think of it as a negative number
and so then just distribute the negative
number so this is going to be 4 negative
2 times 5y as a negative 10y and a
negative
two times a c- three I'm capturing that
sign I get a positive six equals 30 so
now I have to do is combine like terms
that's negative 10y plus 10 equals 30
subtract 10 from both sides we get 20
and divide everything by negative 10 and
you can see y is equal to negative 2 now
you can always check your answer if you
put the negative 2 back in and make sure
you get 30 and you know you've got it
right so let's go to number seven so I
hope you're enjoying this course so far
if you are subscribe to the channel and
again remember if any of these problems
are difficult go to my Mars math
tutoring YouTube channel go to that
little search icon on the channel it's a
little bit further down on the page and
type in you know how do I work with
fractions and you know it'll bring up
those videos that are related to these
topics so number seven says it takes you
twenty-five minutes to paint a fence and
your brother 75 minutes to paint a fence
how long will it take if you work
together
okay so teamwork right this is what they
call a combined rate problem okay
and the idea here is is that in one
minute you paint 125th of the fence okay
times the number of minutes tells you
how much of the fence you've completely
painted right so 4 minutes go by you've
painted four twenty fifths of the fence
and so on so if we go to your brother
now your brother is painting 175th of
the fence times in over minutes that he
works and together you're trying to
compete one whole complete fence now if
it was two fences I would make this
equal to two but the key is rate times
time plus rate times time equals a total
okay and so what I'm gonna do now is
just like we did up with this problem
here is we're gonna clear the
denominators okay cuz maybe we don't to
work with the fractions a common
denominator 75 I'm gonna multiply
everything by 75 left middle and right
okay the whole thing so if I do that
that's going to give us 3t plus 1 T
equals 75 so for T is equal to 75 and if
we divide by 4 I'm just gonna go to the
calculator to get an approximation on
that that's going to be what 75 divided
by 4 18 point seven five minutes is what
you should get for this one okay
eighteen point seven five minutes okay
now let's go to number eight that says
solve for M
you know this is a typical problem but
what makes this a little bit more
challenging this problem is that there's
an M in this term and there's an M in
this term so how do we get the M by
itself because when you want to solve
for a variable you want to isolate the
variable right well the key here is to
do the distributive property like we
were talking about in this problem but
backwards you're trying to factor out
the M so I'm dividing out M out of this
group and M out of this group which
leaves us with 3n minus 9 equals 12 then
all we have to do is instead of
multiplying by 3n minus 9 let's divide
both sides by 3n minus 9 and that's it
so you can see M is equal to 12 divided
by 3n minus 9 so if you're enjoying this
video again you can go down to the
description and click on any of the
timestamps to take you to a particular
video if there's problems you want to
focus on more but otherwise let's go to
the next question okay number 9 it says
write a function that represents the
table values okay and so you can see
this XY table here well the thing that
you want to recognize here is the change
in Y okay and the change in X okay the
change in the Y values the change in the
X values you can see that the Y values
are going down by 5 each time right and
as the X values are going up by 1 each
time okay so what that tells us is it
tells us that the change in Y over the
change in X which remember is the slope
is a negative 5 over positive 1 which is
negative 5 so that's our slope and our
initial condition or our y-intercept is
going to be this key point right here
when X is 0 that's the starting point
that's the B value in our slope
intercept form y equals MX plus B so in
this case we have a slope of negative 5
but the y intercept is positive 20 now
the nice thing about this is you can
check your answer so you can say like
say for example X is 3 that's negative
15 plus 20 yep that gives us an output
of 5
okay so slope intercept form again now
number 10 it says graph on a number line
these two inequalities okay well let's
start with this one first now this is
called a compound inequality and the key
here is you want to graph this on a
number line you want to put the smaller
num
on the left the larger number on the
right so here's negative 2 0 somewhere
here in the middle here's positive 5 but
you can see that X is sandwiched in
between negative 2 & 5 it's greater than
negative 2 okay but not equal to so
that's gonna be an open circle and X is
less than or equal to 5 okay so equal to
means it includes that point and you're
in between those two values okay so
you're with me now Part B it says X is
less than or equal to negative 3 so
here's negative 3 less than or equal to
means it includes that point because of
the equal sign less than means smaller
or to the left or X is greater than 5
but not equal to so greater than means
that is open it doesn't include that
point or greater includes the points to
the right of 5 so that's graphing on the
number line if you're preparing for the
AC T or the SAT check out my two courses
that I put together for you once called
a huge AC T math review video course
other ones called a huge SAT math review
video course and a lot of students have
taken them so far they've been able to
boost their scores there's a teaching
section we go through example problems
two together to help students understand
the underlying concepts and see typical
type problems we go through formulas and
ways to approach the problem so that
they can maximize their math section
score so check those out let's continue
on to question number 11 here these are
absolute value problems so a lot of
times these stumped students okay and
students get these problems wrong when
they go to take the midterm because they
just forget how it works and so let me
see I can kind of explain this to you
the idea here is that we've got an equal
we've got a lesson we've got a greater
than so when it's the equal to what this
really means is it means the distance
between some number and two is five
units right it means it could be 5 units
smaller it could be 5 units greater okay
it's basically saying the distance is
going to be 5 units away so if you go to
the number line see here's here's 2 it
could be 5 units greater they could be
over here at 7 or it could be 5 units
less it could be here at negative 3 so
these are our two answers and you can
put those in negative 3 minus 2 is
negative 5 take the absolute value
that's 5 same thing with 7 so - to take
the absolute value that's 5 but a lot of
times students want to know you know how
do I actually set up the problem and
what I would do
as I would write two equations I'd say X
minus two equals positive 5 or X minus 2
equals negative 5 so when you think of
the absolute value of what it's saying
is it saying the distance from 0 okay it
could be to the left it could be to the
right so all atha do now is add 2 to
both sides we get 7 add 2 to both sides
we get negative 3 same thing as in this
geometric way of solving it
ok Part B though this is a less than
problem and what this is telling us is
that you know that this value has to be
smaller than 5 okay and so what we can
do with a problem like this when it's
less than is we can write it as a
compound inequality what you do is you
say 3x minus 1 is less than 5 and it's
greater than negative 5 so you take
whatever's in the absolute value you put
it in between the negative quantity and
the positive quantity and then I'll have
to do is solve this compound inequality
the way I would do that is they had add
1 to the middle the right and to the
left okay so if we do that we get 3x is
less than 6 and greater than negative 4
if we divide everything by 3 left middle
and right we get negative 4/3 is less
than X is less than 2 so with less than
again you want to treat that as a
compound inequality no one greater then
okay when you think of and okay less
than you think of and when you think of
great or or you think of or so what you
would do for this one is you'd say X
plus 1 is greater than 4 or X plus 1 is
less than negative 4 okay so see what I
did there as I flip the sign to the
opposite and I flip this number to the
opposite as well so X plus 1 is greater
than 4 or X plus 1 is less than negative
4 so if we subtract 1 from both sides we
get X is greater than 3 or subtract 1
from both sides or X is less than
negative 5 so this is the answer here
both of these together so greater than
is an or less than is an an I'll have a
link to more problems that I did for
this one this is a kind of a challenging
path stuff so you can see the video I
did on that I go into more detail but
number 12 here it just asked us to solve
this compound inequality this is very
similar to the one we just did right
here again our goal is to get X by
itself in the middle
and the way we do that is we add six to
the left middle and right okay so now
we're down to three X is less than 30
but greater than or equal to 18 and then
we divide everything by three because
we're just trying to get X by itself so
we get x is less than 10 and X is
greater than 6 so 6 is in between 6 and
10 okay the number 13 we're talking
about domain and range and we're also
talking about is this relation a
function I remember a relation is a
pairing of two sets and input in an
output an ax and a y a domain and a
range so if the key here is the domain
are the X values so that's going to be
negative 4 negative 1 and 5 so negative
4 negative 1 and 5 you could list them
like that or you can use these set
brackets and ideally you want to put
them from low to high okay and then for
the range the range or the outputs those
are the Y values and again same thing
negative 3 negative 3 and 2 but since
negative 3 is listed twice I'm just
gonna write it once if you don't have to
write it twice you just list it once and
again low to high is ideal but Part B
said is the relation a function I
remember not every relation is a
function a function is for a given input
there's only one output again I always
like to use the example of a vending
machine you go up to a vending machine
you say I'm gonna have something to
drink
you press say a 3 if one time a Coca
Cola comes out the next time a Mountain
Dew comes up do you know what you're
gonna get you know you really don't know
you just press that button you know it's
unpredictable so you only want for every
input you only want one output so let's
take a look so when I put negative 4 in
I get negative 3 when I put negative 1
in I get negative 3 now some students
will think well this is not a function
they say well wait you got negative 3
twice what you don't want is you don't
want the same input going to two
different outputs so if I had negative 4
goes to negative 3 and then over here I
had negative 4 goes to 7 I would have
that same input negative 4 going to 2
different you know outputs and that's
the unpredictable right you don't know
what you're gonna get it's okay to have
the same input I'm sorry different
inputs going to the same output that's
okay you could press a 3 get them out
and do or press a 7 get them out and do
you know what you're gonna get when you
press those numbers because there's only
one output and then again 5 goes to 2 so
in this case yes the domain the relation
is a
function so we're gonna say yes for that
one okay question number 14 says which
function is not linear so remember
linear means is like a straight line
okay
now when you look at letter a x squared
minus 3x plus 2 you see this squared
second degree equation that means that
this is a parabola like this and that
means it's not linear so this one's not
linear letter B you can see this is in
the form y equals MX plus B that is a
straight line so we're gonna say yes for
this one and then for letter C H of x
equals 4 that's a like y equals 4 that's
a horizontal line like this okay and so
this one also is linear so the one
that's not linear here would be the
first one the x squared one okay number
15 it says fine n so the line through
negative 4 6 comma 2 n has a slope of 1
6 well what you can do here is they're
testing us on the slope formula remember
the slope formula y2 minus y1 over x2
minus x1 it's the rise over the run so
if we do that let's see let's do 6 minus
2 I'm sorry 6 minus n y minus y over X
minus ax now the order is important you
want to make sure that you if you make
this point number 2 this is point number
1 or you can switch it around this is
point number 2 this is point number 1
and we're going to set that equal to 1/6
now what I'm going to do here is I'm
going to cross multiply on the diagonal
ok so if we do that we get 36 minus 6 N
equals now this is negative 6 times 1 is
negative 6 and then if we subtract 36
from both sides we get negative 6 N
equals negative 42 divided by negative 6
and you can see that n is equal to 7
okay the next one number 16 says are the
lines parallel or perpendicular now what
they're testing us on in this problem is
you know do we know the slope and if the
slopes are the same that means they're
going up at the same rate and that means
that they're parallel if the slopes are
opposite reciprocals of each other
meaning they're the opposite sign ones
positive ones negative or vice versa and
the reciprocal you flip it over the case
was the combination goes to so we're
gonna use a slope formula we did up here
and let's go ahead and do that so 1
minus 2 is negative 1 over negative 2
minus negative
when you subtract a negative it's like
adding a positive so that's going to be
4 so that has a slope of negative 1/4
over here 9 minus 5 is 4 over 3 minus 2
which is 1 and you can see this is a
negative this is a positive and the 1 is
the reciprocal of the other so that
means that these two lines are
perpendicular if they were both negative
1/4 or if they were both 4 they'd be
going up at the same rate and they would
be parallel okay so that's talking about
slopes number 17 asks us to graph this
line and the easiest way to graph this
line in my opinion when it's in this
form is to make a table set X to 0 to
find the y-intercept set Y to 0 to find
the x intercept so if you set X to 0 I'm
covering this up because 0 times
anything is 0 divide both sides by
negative 6 you can see Y is going to be
negative 3 and if you set Y to 0 0 times
anything is 0 I'm covering that up
divided by 3x is going to be 6 so if we
plot those points 0 negative 3 and 6 0
all I have to do is get out a ruler and
draw a line through those two points
okay the other way to do this is to
rearrange the equation by solving for y
and put it into the slope intercept form
the y equals MX plus B form if any of
these concepts seemed challenging to you
I did a video on algebra one final exam
and it talks about some of these
concepts it's a giant algebra 1 exam
review you can check that out on my
channel if you're interested but let's
keep going as we go through these
problems going to get more challenging
this is write an equation line that
passes through 1 negative 3 and has a
slope of negative 2 in slope intercept
form so remember slope intercept form is
the y equals MX plus B form we have to
find the slope we have to find that
y-intercept well they tell us the slope
is negative 2 so let's put that in for M
now we have to solve for B and you can
see they're giving us Y is negative 3
when X is 1 so if we solve this we get
negative 2 ok here and if we solve for B
by adding 2 to both sides you can see
that this comes out to be equals
negative 1 so all we have to do is put
that back in here and we've got y equals
negative 2x minus 1 and that's the
equation of our line ok question number
19 if you're enjoying this video by the
way give it a thumbs up so I know to
make more videos like these in the
future
but it says write the equation of the
line that passes through the point 4
negative 3 and it's parallel to y equals
1/2 X plus 1 in point-slope form so the
last question we did number 18 was
slope-intercept form but remember
point-slope form is y minus y1 equals M
times X minus x1 x1 y1 is your point M
is your slope so in this case if it's
parallel we know that it has the same
slope as this line so that means that M
is going to be 1/2 and if it goes
through the point 4 negative 3 this is
going to be X minus the x-coordinate of
the point y minus the y coordinate of
the point but then this negative and
that negative cancel and give you a
positive ok so this is your equation in
point-slope form number 20 says write
the equation of the line that passes
through negative 2 5 and 6 4 in standard
form now remember standard form is ax
plus B y equals C ok so you get the
variables on the left numbers on the
right a B and C are integers and a is
positive so that's the key for standard
form but what we got to do is let's
start with either point-slope form or
slope-intercept form and then we'll
convert it into the standard form so
first I'm gonna do is I'm going to find
the slope so 4 minus 5 is negative 1 6
minus negative 2 is 8 so we know we have
a slope of 8 and let's just pick take
this point over here we've got Y minus
the y coordinate X minus the x
coordinate see the two negatives cancel
now we've got it in point-slope form we
want to convert it into slope-intercept
form so I'm going to distribute the
negative 1/8 so that gives us let's see
negative 1/8 X let's see minus two
eighths this is y minus 5 I'm going to
clear the denominators by multiplying
through by eight so that's going to give
us 8y minus 40 equals negative x minus 2
I'm going to get the variables on the
left so I'm going to add 2x to this side
so we get X plus 8y and I'm going to add
240 to both sides so that's going to
give us 38 ok now you can see this is in
standard form because we have the
variables on the left the coefficients
the a B and C are integers and the a
value is positive if this was negative
I'd multiply through everything by a
negative 1 okay let's go to number 21 it
says if your starting salary in 2019 is
$48,000 and it increases by $5,000 per
year or write an equation that gives us
80 years after 2019 now sometimes
students gonna be confused by this but
if we're starting at 2019 that's like
your zero that's our initial condition
which is the 48 thousand so if we use
the slope-intercept form y equals MX
plus B that B that initial value that
starting value is 48,000 the slope
that's the rate of increase or decrease
in this case your salary is going by
5,000 per year so the M value is going
to be 5,000 instead of X I'm going to
use T for years instead of Y I'm going
to write ask for your salary
okay so again slope-intercept form on
that one just in a story problem format
number 22 says the number of miles M
that you can bike varies directly with
the number of hours each spent pedaling
you can travel 30 miles in 4 hours
write the equation relating M and T and
then how many miles can you bike after
you pedal for seven hours now what
they're testing us on in this question
is the form of the direct variation so y
equals a times ax or y equals K times X
it depends how your your book writes it
but a or K is called a constant of
variation or its you can think about it
like the slope so what we would do is
we'd set this up as M miles equals a or
constant of variation
times T and they give us a little hint
they say you travel 30 miles after 4
hours now if I divide both sides by 4 a
is 7.5 so our equation is going to be M
equals 7.5 T so now we have a direct
variation equation that relates the time
pedaling and number of miles traveled
okay and Part B says how many miles can
you bike after 7 hours all we have to do
is put seven hours in 40 and we got it
so I'll go to the calculator on that one
C 7.5 times 750 2.5 miles remember the
story problems you always want to put
your your units okay 50 2.5 miles okay
question number 23 tell whether the
table shows direct variation if so write
the equation now remember direct
variation are equations that are in the
form y equals a times X or y equals K
times ax
but what I want to show you is if you
get this a by itself by dividing both
sides by X what you'll find is that if
you divide the Y value by the x value
and you get the same quantity each time
that tells you it's direct variation so
let's test that out if we do negative 36
divided by negative 9 what do we get 4
what's negative told them of a negative
3 for 12 by 3 4 4 4 4 4 right so that
tells us that Y is equal to 4 times X
now you can always test it out you know
put a value in for X 4 times 15 yep 60
you know you got it so I have more
examples like this of all these problems
on my Mara's math tutor YouTube channel
so if you're having difficulty you know
go ahead and you know go over there and
see if you can get some other videos
like that to take a look at and I going
through it in more detail but let's go
to number 24 so here what they have is
us doing some graphing type problems
here we're graphing an absolute value
here we're graphing an inequality you're
graphing another inequality so let's
take a look at this so the first thing
we're going to do here is we're going to
notice that this is in the form Y is
equal to a times X minus H plus K HK is
the vertex so this is actually going to
be a positive 3 the one group of the X
here is the opposite sign positive 3 and
this one's going to be the same sign
positive 2 so I'm going to go right 3 up
2 that's the vertex that's where the
graph bends now remember absolute value
graphs have these v-shaped graphs a real
sharp corner there then if you look at
the a value in front in this case it's 1
okay because there wasn't anything there
1 times anything is itself that's really
like the slope that's how steeply that
the absolute value graph goes up so in
this case it's going up 1 over 1 up 1
over 1 you can go left and right because
it's symmetric about that vertex this is
like a line of symmetry okay so real
easy to graph those this one here
what I would do is I would do like we
did some of the other graphs we'd set X
to 0 solve for the y-intercept so you
can see that's going to be negative to
set Y to 0 divided by 2 that means X is
going to be 4 notice that it's less than
but not equal to which means it's going
to be a dashed or dotted line then if we
pick a test point origin is a good point
to pick 0 0 so if we put 0 in and 0 in
we get 0 is less than 8 is that true yes
so where that point is that's the true
side of the plane that's where we want
to shade if it
false you would shade the other side of
the plane and then the last one X is
less than or equal to three well we know
that X lines are going to be vertical
lines like that no matter what the Y
value is X is always fixed at 3 but you
can see it's equal to which is why I
drew it as a solid line if it was just
less than I would ruin it drawing it as
a dotted line and X is less than equal
to 3 less than means that we're going to
the left when it comes to the x value if
it was greater than we would be going to
the right so we want that X values that
are less than 3 meanings to the left so
I would shade this side of the plane
again you can do the test point method
put 0 0 in that's true so you know
you're shading the correct side of the
plane so I hope this is helping you so
far we've got a lot more questions to go
through a ton of information in here to
help you with your midterm or if you're
just trying to review algebra in general
but number 25 says write the equation of
the parabola with vertex at the origin
and directrix at x equals negative 2 now
I always like to draw a picture just
helps me visualize a little bit better
so that's the vertex the directrix is at
x equals negative 2 that's a vertical
line and so that means it's going to be
opening away from the directrix and the
focus is going to be over here it's
going to be the same distance we call
that distance P from the vertex to the
directrix or the vertex to the focus and
in this case you can see that p value is
2 okay so the equation when it's opening
to the left or right is going to be Y
squared equals 4p X if it opens up or
down it's going to be x squared equals
4p Y so basically in this case we can
see we're looking at Y squared equals 4
times 2 which is 8 X if it opened to the
left then this would be a negative 8
okay so I have a lot of videos I
actually have a parabola playlist on my
Mario's math tutor YouTube channel if
you want to learn all about parabolas I
would definitely go through those video
that video series but number 26 now this
is a another form of a parabola this is
basically called the general form of the
parabola it's in the form y equals ax
squared plus BX plus C and you can see
that the a is 1 the B is 10 and the C is
3 and it says state the vertex axis
symmetry y-intercept and graph it right
so basically when you find the vertex
this is the formula you want to remember
x equals negative
over 2a that gives you the ax quarter of
the vertex it also gives you the axis of
symmetry the line that divides the
parabola on half it's the same on both
sides so in this case it's going to be
the opposite of B which is negative 10
over 2 times a which is 1 so that comes
out to 2 negative 10 divided by 2 is
negative 5
okay so negative 5 is our x-coordinate
of our vertex if we put negative 5 back
in we get our y-value of our vertex so
if we do that we get negative 50
positive 25 which is a negative 25 if
you add those together plus 3 is a
negative 22 so that's our vertex right
there axis of symmetry is going to be
going through the x-coordinate of vertex
that's x equals negative 5 the
y-intercept is where the x-coordinate is
0 okay so if we put 0 in for X you can
see that the y-intercept is 3 ok and if
we graph it we can take this information
that we've gathered like the vertex
negative 5 negative 22 we'll just say
it's way down here ok the axis of
symmetry
ok divides a parabola in half but
y-intercept at 3 we do the mirror image
over that line ok now we've got some key
points you know and we can sketch them
real quickly like that so that's
graphing parabolas again check out that
playlist parabolas on my mario's math
tutor youtube channel but we're gonna be
doing more problems like this as an
important concept in algebra 2 okay
number 27 another parabola problem but
this parabola has been given it to us in
the form y equals a times X minus H
squared plus K this is called a vertex
form remember H comma K is the vertex
the a is what stretches the parabola
vertically or compresses it vertically
if it's negative reflects it makes it
open downward but let's see it's asking
us where the vertex axis of symmetry Y&R
something to graph it so you can see the
vertex is going to be at positive 2
comma 3 remember the one that's grouped
with the X has the opposite sign this K
value over here has the same sign the
axis of symmetry is going to be through
that x coordinate of the vertex so
that's going to be x equals 2 the y
intercept is a little bit more
challenging we have to set X equal to
zero because remember when X is zero
we're not going left to right we're
going to be right on the y axis so if we
put 0 in for X we get 0 minus 2 which is
negative 2 negative 2 squared is 4 times
3 is 12 plus 3 is 15
and if we graph it let's put all that
information together so the vertex is at
2/3 right there the axis of symmetry is
x equals 2 like that the y-intercept is
way up here at 15 and if we reflect that
over the line meaning if you go to to
the left you want to go to to the right
that's also going to be at 15 and we can
quickly get a nice sketch of our
parabola now number 28 this is the form
of a parabola but an intercept form okay
and it asks for the x-intercepts the
vertex the axis of symmetry under
graphic so here what you do this is like
factored form you set each of these
factors equal to 0 to find the x
intercept so if I set X plus 4 equal to
0 I get negative 4 and if I set X minus
2 equal to 0 I get positive 2 so those
are the x-intercepts so we'll just say
negative 4 and 2 and then the vertex ok
what we have to do is we have to find
the axis of symmetry now the axis of
symmetry is going to be halfway in
between these two and the easiest way to
do that is just to add them together and
divide by 2
so negative 4 plus 2 is negative 2
divided by 2 is negative 1 or you can
just kind of count you know and find the
middle like that but it doesn't always
work out to a nice round number so
that's why I did the midpoint formula
add them together and divide by 2 so the
axis of symmetry set is x equals
negative 1 and then now if you put
negative 1 back in for X you can get the
y coordinate of the vertex we've got the
x coordinate so let's put that in
negative 1 plus 4 is 3 negative 1 minus
2 is negative 3 if we multiply all that
together we get let's see we get
negative 9 times negative 1/2 is
positive 9 halves which is 4.5 right so
that's at negative 1 four point five one
two three four five four point five
would be right about there we've already
got three points so we can get a pretty
good sketch of our graph like so so
again you can go to that playlist I have
about parabolas on my Mara's math to
your YouTube channel to learn all about
parabolas all the different forms
definitely important concept especially
if you're preparing for the AC T and the
SAT but let's look at number 29 this is
what they're giving us here is what they
call the vertical motion model vertical
motion means like you know going up and
down in a vertical
you've probably seen this equation if
you're studying physics or some of your
science classes but basically T is your
time generally it's in seconds the V sub
zero means the velocity at time zero the
initial upward velocity and then this s
here is the initial height or the
initial you know position and the height
is how high it is after T seconds okay
so it's good to memorize this equation
if you don't know it already but a lot
of times I'll provide it for you so it
says find the height of a ball after
three seconds and has been thrown upward
with an initial velocity of 40 feet per
second at initial height of 100 feet
well let's see so we've got H equals
negative 16t squared plus 40 T because
that's an initial velocity plus the
initial height of 100 and it says find
the height after 3 seconds well that
means we're just putting in 340 okay so
let me go to the calculator really quick
see if we can simplify this so the 3
squared is 9 times negative 16 is a
negative 144 right plus 40 times 3 is
120 plus 100 means that it's gonna be at
a height of 76 feet after 3 seconds okay
and you can check my math on that
okay letter B says one will ball ball
hit the ground well okay one thing
you'll notice is that this is a parabola
right because of the C the x squared the
T squared parabola have either u-shaped
graphi they're opening up like this
they're opening down like this but
because the a values negative means it's
opening down so basically what you can
think about is this is gonna look
something like that
it's going to go up it's gonna come down
let's gonna hit the ground but well the
question is is what's the height of the
ball okay when it hits the ground well
when it hits the ground the height is
gonna be 0 that's the key in this
question they don't come out and say it
but the height is 0 so if we set H equal
to 0 let's do that here we have our
equation like this and we want to solve
for 40 but notice this might not be so
easy to factor so what I recommend on a
problem like this is just to go to the
quadratic formula now remember the
quadratic formula is when you have an
equation in the form ax squared plus BX
plus C equals 0 okay that's the key you
wanna get everything on one side set to
0 and then our x value is going to be
the opposite of B plus or minus the
square root of b squared minus 4ac all
divided by 2a and I've got more videos
like this talking about quadratic
for me a formula on my Mario's math
tutoring YouTube channel if you want to
check out more there but I'll just set
it up for us right here so this is going
to be 40 squared minus 440 times
negative 16 times 100 all divided by two
times a okay now one thing you'll notice
is there's a plus or minus sign there
what does that mean well it means that
you're going to get two answers
potentially but let's see if we can
simplify this so I'm going to set this
up here in the calculator negative 40
plus the square root of 40 squared which
is 1600 negative times a negative
positive that 64 times 100 is 6400 right
so let's just add that in there okay
let's see all right and I'm going to
divide that by negative 32 because 2
times negative 16 is negative 32 so we
get negative 1.5 seconds but that
doesn't make sense because that's like
going backwards in time whoops so
basically what happens is they're going
backwards okay we don't want a negative
time so what I'm going to do is instead
of doing positive here I'm going to do
negative so I can find this value over
here so let me go it back to the
calculator and let's see what that comes
out to you so we get okay second entry
change this to - oh we get a four point
zero five seconds okay so that's gonna
be over here so it's going to take time
equals four point zero five seconds so
discard the negative answer you just
want the positive answer in this case
letter C it says what is the maximum
height we're trying to find this point
right here now if you have a graphing
calculator of course you can graph it
find this maximum value if you need help
with that you can check out my ti-83 and
ti-84 tutorials on my youtube channel
but the other way to do that is to use
the negative B over 2a formula we used
earlier in this video to find the the
coordinates of the vertex so negative B
is going to be negative 40 over 2 times
a which is negative 16 and then what
you're going to do is you're going to
take that value you're going to put it
back in 40 and you're gonna solve for H
now I'm going to do it here now because
I know some students are probably going
to ask me what's the answer so let me
just see if I can figure it out real
quick for us negative 40 divided by
negative 32 one point two five seconds
it reaches that maximum height so I'm
gonna put one point two five back in
so let me see if I can do that store
under X value we've got negative 16x
squared you guys can check my math on
this and make sure that I'm doing it
correctly okay and so it looks like it's
coming out to 125 feet so that's going
to be your maximum height after one
point two five seconds 125 feet okay
number 30 we're almost to the halfway
point of this midterm review so what do
you think are you guys gonna score well
on the exam let me know in the comments
below so let's see factoring now all
right so we've come to that part of the
review well first thing you want to do
here is you notice it's a trinomial you
know this the leading coefficient is 1
what you want to do in a situation like
this is you want to ask yourself what
two numbers multiply to the last term
negative 12 but add to that middle
coefficient so in this case we've got X
and X that gives us x squared but what
two numbers multiply to negative 12 but
add to negative one that's going to be
negative 4 and positive 3 now the nice
thing about factoring is you can foil it
out and check to see if you get back the
original okay so let's go to letter B
now now here what you notice there's
only two terms the terms are separated
by minus or plus this is what's called a
difference of two squares when you
factor a big difference of two squares
you want to take the square root of both
of these quantities so square root of 25
squared is 5 C is square root of 81 is 9
and you make one of these positive and
one negative again you can foil this out
and make sure you get back the original
remember though the first step in
factoring is always the greatest common
factor so check for that first and do
that first I've got a really good video
it's about 20 minutes long it goes
through all the different types of
factoring I'll try to see if I can put a
link in that when I go to do the editing
for this video but it's called learn how
to factor and you can check that out on
my youtube channel Mario's math tutoring
now this one we can use a trial and
error method or we can do splitting the
middle term and factoring by grouping
I'm just gonna head and use the guess
and check method method or the trial and
error method and do the foil backwards
so I'm gonna say maybe 2 X + 3 X that
gives us 6 x squared and what two
numbers multiply to negative 15 well
let's see the positive 5 and negative 3
so then I would have to do is check the
inner product and the outer product
that's negative 9x that
of 10-x dad's if the middle term 1x of
course the last term is multiplied to
the negative 15 the last term and then
the two first terms multiplied to the
first term so I know I've got it so
let's go to number 31 solving this
equation well the first thing you want
to do is you want to get everything on
one side of the equation
okay the equal sign and set it equal to
zero so I subtract to the three D and I
subtracted the 24 to get everything on
the left and set it to zero then we're
back to we were doing up here which is
just a factor and we say what two
numbers multiply to negative 24 but add
to negative three well that's going to
be let's see is it going to be negative
no it's gonna be hmm let me see what do
we got here eaten five no eight and
three that doesn't work six and four
doesn't work so in this particular one I
would do the quadratic formula so I've
got everything on one side I would do
the quadratic formula so I would do
negative B which is gonna give us
positive 3 plus or minus the square root
of B squared which is 9 minus 4 times a
times C all divided by 2 times a now
when I was creating this problem
originally I was intending for this to
work out using factoring but again if it
doesn't that's what the quadratic
formula is there for and you can go
ahead and simplify this to get the
solutions to this problem so I'll let
you do that one post the answer in the
comments below and you can check with
each other to see if you got the right
answer and now let's see so find the
zeros so now what does it mean when it
says find the zeros well when they say
find the zeros they mean that the output
the y-value is zero so you set this
equal to zero and you solve and you can
either do that by factoring and setting
the factors to zero or by doing the
quadratic formula like we did up here
and this one we can factor this 2x minus
5 X plus 3 because negative 5x and
positive 3x add up to negative 2x but
the negative 5 times positive 3 give you
you the negative 15 now if we set each
group equal to 0 we get x equals 5 or x
equals negative 3 and those are going to
be our solutions again you can check by
putting them back in to see if you get 0
but remember finding the zeros just
means that's the output or the Y value
equal to 0 now for number 33 we're
getting into radicals now the case we're
reviewing radicals and it says to
simplify so square root of 3 times
square root of 24 is actually what the
square root of 72 now we try to divide
out perfect squares and ideally you want
to
divide out the largest perfect square
which in this case would be 36 times 2
is 72 square root of 36 is just going to
be 6 so this is 6 square root of 2 now
I've got a video it's called simplifying
radicals easy method and that video is
really popular a lot of students have
benefited from that so you might want to
check that one out
this one what we want to do is we want
to combine like terms but you can see
there's nothing in common so if we
simplify square root of 32 is 16 times 2
square root of 16 is 4 so we get 4 root
2 20 we can factor out a 4 square root
of 4 is 2 so we get 2 root 5 so now if
we look we can see we can combine these
3 square roots of 2 plus 4 square roots
of 2 is 7 square roots of 2 minus 2
square roots of 5 now we can't combine
these any further because these either
have to be both square roots of 5 or
both square roots of 2 they're different
terms so we can't combine them this one
here 3 over 2 minus root 5 we want to
simplify this and when you're
simplifying fractions like this you
don't want the radical in the
denominator so what you want to do is
you want to multiply by what's called
the conjugate so what's the conjugate
exactly well it's the same thing as what
we have here in the denominator 2 minus
root 5 but what you do is you change its
sign from negative to positive or if
this was positive you change that to
negative now when you have a binomial
times a binomial you foil here we have
online monomial times a binomial we just
have to distribute so let's go ahead and
simplify we get 3 times 2 is 6 3 times
root 5 is 3 root 5 and the denominator
what's interesting about multiplying by
the conjugate is that the inside and the
outside cancels so native to root 5 and
positive 2 root 5 those cancel we just
get a first in the last 2 times 2 is 4
negative root 5 times positive root 5 is
negative square root of 25 square root
25 is five but it's a negative so it'd
be negative 5 4 minus 5 is negative 1 if
we divide both these terms by negative 1
we can simplify this to negative 6 minus
3 square roots of 5 again check out more
videos on my youtube channel about
simplifying radicals number 34 it says
simplify and write in standard form a
plus bi form that's the standard form of
a complex number so we've got some more
examples of radicals here but you can
see when you take the square root of a
negative number what do you get well
remember this is very important square
root of negative 1
use the letter I to represent the square
root of negative one so we can really
break this down into square root of
negative 1 times square root of 16 times
square root of 3 because these all
multiply to negative 48 the reason I did
this is because 16 is a perfect square
square root of 16 is 4 negative 1 square
a negative on is I so we get 4i
square root of 3 okay that's what it
equals and then over here what we're
doing is we're combining two complex
numbers a plus bi a plus bi we're
subtracting these two complex numbers so
what we have is 3 minus 4 which is
negative 1 and we have negative 5i minus
2i which is negative 7i now what a lot
of students like to do is distribute the
negative because subtraction is like
adding the opposite or distribute the
negative and then you can just combine
like terms but you always want the real
first limit ok question number 36 it
says all these equations okay well I'm
gonna do letter B first it says 3 times
X minus 1 squared minus 4 equals 11 now
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
work from the outside in towards that X
by doing the opposite so what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to add 4 to both sides
so that equals 15 ok so you're with me
so far
divide both sides by 3 so that gives us
x minus squared X minus 1 squared equals
5 and then I'm gonna do the opposite of
squaring which is take the square root
of both sides but remember when you do
that you get two answers plus or minus
square root of 5 the square and the
square root cancel each other out and
then if I add the 1 I get x equals 1
plus or minus square root of 5 and you
want to add that 1 in front of the plus
or minus okay but going back to letter a
what I would do here is I would do a
similar sort of a situation I would
subtract 2 so that gives us x squared
minus 4x and then what I'm going to do
is I'm going to complete the square so
half of negative 4 is negative 2
negative 2 squared is positive 4 but you
want to add it to both sides to keep the
equation balanced right if i factor this
I get X minus 2 squared equals 2 and
then we're back to where that we were at
this step right here so I want to take
the square root of both sides
remember when you do that you get two
answers you get X minus 2 equals
positive root 2 and you get X minus 2
equals negative root 2 then you can just
add 2 to both sides of the equation like
so and so you're going to get x equals 2
plus or minus
square root of two okay so that's
completing the square and basically
you're working from the outside in then
after you complete the square to solve
for X number 37 says find the
discriminant and tell how many X
intercepts a graph has well first of all
what is the discriminant well the
discriminant is the b squared minus 4ac
that's the part that's underneath the
square root in the quadratic formula and
remember this goes like this a B and C
so if we figure out what b square minus
4ac is that's going to be three squared
minus four times a times C that gives us
9 minus 40 which equals negative 31 but
now here's the thing when the
discriminant comes out to a negative
number you get zero solutions and what
that means is that the parabola is not
crossing the x-axis at all if it comes
out to zero that means that you're
getting one solution it's touching right
at the vertex and if it comes out to a
positive value you're getting two
solutions as crossing the x-axis at two
points but because this is negative it
really means that there's no
x-intercepts so it says determine the
x-intercepts we're just gonna say none
okay so going on to number 38 it says
use your calculator to write a quadratic
function that passes through these three
points now there's a lot of different
ways to do this one way it would be to
write a system of equations because
you've got three variables and three
unknowns in your y equals ax squared
plus BX plus C another method is to use
the quadratic quadratic regression
feature on your calculator by plugging
these values in your data and then going
the quadratic regression it'll calculate
it for you there's a lot of different
techniques but I think what I'm going to
do is I'm going to direct you to the
video that I did on writing the equation
of a quadratic given three points so you
can check out that video for little bit
more information see if you can do this
on your own I calculated this a little
bit earlier here for us and it looks
like the equation should come out to y
equals x squared let's see where is it y
equals x squared minus three X plus four
so that's what you should get but if
it's multiple choice you can always try
plugging the points in and making sure
that you know it makes the equation true
for all three points that's another way
to approach it
now number 39 says simplify each
expression okay so here we're working
with
exponents negative exponents and so on
so here we've got three divided by 12 3
goes into 3 once 3 goes into 12 4 times
so I just reduce but when you subtract
what do you do to the exponents when you
divide what do you do the exponents they
gave away the answer you subtract
negative 2 minus 1 is negative 3 right
you put the answer in the numerator and
then over here or when you divide you
subtract 0 minus 3 is d to the negative
3rd now you don't want negative
exponents in the final answer so what do
you do anything that has a negative
exponent you move it to the other side
of the fraction bar if it was down here
you move it up to the top if it's in the
top you move to the bottom the negative
is just telling you to take the
reciprocal okay so that's the idea for
letter a now for letter B what we have
is we have a power to a power now what
do you do when you have a power to a
power well you have to distribute that
okay that power and you multiply it so
power to power you multiply so you don't
really see it but 2 is to the first so 1
times negative 3 gives you 2 to the
negative 3 negative 2 times negative 3
is 6 3 times negative 3 is negative 9
and same thing the denominates 5 to the
negative 3 and then Y to the negative 6
okay now remember when you divide you
subtract so if we have the same base
like here we have both base Y negative 9
minus negative 6 is going to be negative
3 so we get X to the sixth Y to the
negative 3rd that 2 I'm going to bring
to the denominator the 5 I'm going to
bring to the numerator because the
negative exponent tells you to take the
reciprocal so that's going to be 5 cubed
up here 2 cubed down here also the Y I
can bring down to the denominator
because it has a negative exponent and
I'm going to simplify so 5 cubed is 125
X to the 6 2 cubed is 8 and then I'm
gonna bring the Y down to the
denominator Y cubed and you got it so
testing us on negative exponents really
important now for this one what I would
probably do a lot of students can be
confused about this but I think the
easiest way to do it is multiply the
numerators together and the denominators
together so that's what I'm gonna do
right here okay so I'm multiplying just
horizontally across okay so that comes
out to let's see and I like to put it in
alphabetical order if possible so that's
the idea and then you can see the 30s
are going to reduce to 1/2 minus
negative 2 gives you X to the 4th 5
minus negative 2 gives you
why to the seventh and that's your final
answer so the key I think is to multiply
the numerators together Dena which
together get it into one fraction and
when you divide you subtract okay as
long as the bases are the same and then
with the numbers you just reduce okay
question number 40 says write in
scientific notation so here's the thing
when you know when you multiply you
divide we're using the rules of
exponents but we're applying it to
scientific numbers so here are one point
eight divided by three point six that's
actually zero point five right it's a
half but when you divide and you have
the same base what do you do you
subtract the exponents so four minus
negative three gives us 10 to the
seventh but you can see this is not in
scientific notation we have to move this
decimal point so that there's just a
single digit in front of or to the left
of the decimal point so when we do that
we actually are making this number
larger by a power of 10 so to
counterbalance that we're going to
subtract one from this power of 10
exponent and that's going to make this
10 to the sixth so that's number forty
number forty one they give us this
polynomial and asks us for the degree
the leading coefficient F of negative
one and to describe the end behavior so
first of all the degree well we can
think of the degree you think of the
highest exponent the highest power of X
in this case three is the highest so
we're gonna say it's a degree three or
you could say it's a cubic okay the
leading coefficients the one that leads
it off it's in front of the highest
power term you know the term with the
highest power of X so in this case
that's going to be a negative force when
you write it in descending order that
first one that leading coefficient that
one on the left that's the one we're
looking for and then F of negative one
means we're putting negative one
see whatever's in the parenthesis here
we put that in for X on the right and we
simplify so if we put negative one and
negative one cubed is negative one times
negative 4 is positive 4 negative 1
squared is 1 times 2 is 2 negative 1
times negative 5 is positive 5 and 8 so
all that together we get 19 and then it
says describe the end behavior now what
they're saying here is you know is a
parabola not the parabolas but it does a
poem you're going up to the right down
to the right up to the left down to the
left and it depends on your class and on
your teacher so I'm going to show you
two different ways one way is you could
say because the leading coefficient is
negative it's going down
right but because it's an odd degree
that's going to opposite direction up to
the left so you could say up to left
down to the right the other way to write
this a little bit more mathematical I
guess you could say it would be the
limit as X approaches negative infinity
meaning as the X gets smaller and
smaller as you go to the left the Y
values the f of X values are approaching
positive infinity and the limit as X is
approaching positive infinity meaning as
you're going to the right as X gets
larger and larger the Y values are going
down they're approaching negative
infinity so that's the limit notation
okay now if you're preparing for the AC
T or the SAT check out my two courses my
huge AC t-- math review video course
from a huge SAT math review video course
I go through a number of concepts that
are covered on the test we go through
example problems we go through formulas
there's a teaching section there's
opportunities for you to practice
there's three free previews for both
those courses so check out the free
previews see if it's something that you
think that will be beneficial for you a
lot of students have already taken my
courses and have reported back to me
that their scores have gone up on those
math sections of the AC teen SAT so
check those two out and that'll
definitely help you but let's continue
on with this midterm review so number 42
it says simplify this expression now a
lot of students they make the mistake
when they see this square here they just
square the 5 and the square the 2x you
don't want to do that right you want to
think of this as a binomial which means
two terms squared which means you have
two of them like that so what I probably
would do is I would file these out first
so let's do that 2x times 2x is 4x
squared the outside is 10x inside is 10x
that's 20x and then 5 times 5 is 25 and
then we're multiplying that all by X
minus 2 okay so what I would do is I
would take the X multiply all these by X
the negative to multiple 3 of those my
negative 2 and then combine like terms
let's see if we can do that so x times
4x squared gives us 4x cubed + 20 x
squared + 25 X if I distribute the
negative 2 that gives us negative 8x
squared that gives us negative 40 X and
that gives us negative 50 now I line
them up in this way to make it a little
bit easier so we could just add straight
down
okay so that
gives us 12 x squared plus 50 minus 15 X
minus 15 X minus 50 and you got it right
okay so now number 43 we're getting into
factoring a little bit more challenging
type of factoring problems we did
factoring earlier in this video but here
what we're looking at is a difference of
two cubes so remember when you factor a
difference of two cubes this is the
formula that you want a cube minus B
cube equals a minus B times a squared
plus a B plus B squared now if you're
adding two cubes it's going to be plus
minus plus a lot of students remember
this acronym soap and what it stands for
is the same so if you're subtracting
you're subtracting if you're adding your
heading it's the same sign then it's the
opposite so minus plus plus minus the
last one AP stands for always positive
so think of the soap acronym as a way to
remember the difference of two cubes in
the sum of two cubes but in this case we
can see that 64 C cubed this is really
for C 1 cubed is the cube root that's
just going to be 1 so our a value is 4 C
our B value is 1 so this is going to be
4 C minus 1/4 C squared is 16 C squared
4 C times 1 is 4 C and then 1 squared is
1 and you can't factor it any further
that's as far as you can go this one
here is what they call quadratic form
okay and quadratic form means that you
would know how to factor this if it was
in the form like a quadratic like a M
squared right so you imagine for a
moment if it was like this in your
factoring you'd say hmm what multiplies
to 36 but adds to negative 13 that's
negative 9 and negative 4 right but this
is M to the 6 so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to say M cubed and M cubed and
negative 9 and negative 4 C and then
thing you have to be careful with this
sometimes you can factor further because
they'll say factor completely that means
keep going right but the thing is is
first step is always to factor the
greatest common factor and then you can
proceed from there whether it's a
difference of two cubes difference of
two squares Summa two cubes quadratic
form I talked all about all these types
of factoring in my video learn how to
so check that out on my Morrow's math
tutor and youtube channel now this one
you see how there's four terms the terms
are separated by plus or minus when you
have four terms what you do is you think
about grouping factoring by grouping
okay now there's a plus sign in between
these so then what you do is you factor
out the x squared that's the greatest
common factor same thing here you factor
out the negative four that's the
greatest common factor but notice how we
have an X plus 3 in common if we factor
that out of this group and out of this
group right what are we left with we're
left with x squared minus four now you
can take a look at factoring by grouping
in my youtube channel if you want to
learn more about this but notice this is
a difference of two squares which means
we can factor it further X plus 2 X
minus 2 and we just bring down the X
plus 3 so the factoring you always want
to see if you can factor further so
that's that's important ok number 44 it
says given f of X equals negative 3x
cubed minus 4 x squared plus 1 to find
the local maximum and the zeros so these
are calculator problems and what you
would do and I've done videos on this
before you can go to my ti-83 and ti-84
calculator tutorials but you want to
find you know the local maximum now
local maximum is going to be you know
where it's a high point so where it
bends but you get like a top of the hill
so what you would do in your calculator
is you would select a point to the left
of that maximum to the right of the
maximum and you would say calculate and
we would find that high point so I
calculated this a little bit earlier and
it's in this one if you're doing this at
home you should get a local maximum of
0.18 so that's zero point one eight
comma negative point seven three okay so
you can verify that on your graphing
calculator and then the zeros what
you're doing
same thing you're trying to find out
where the Y coordinates 0 meaning you're
looking for where it crosses the x-axis
again you're going to pick a point
that's to the left of that zero and a
point to the right of that zero one
should be above the x-axis one should be
below and you would say calculate and it
would zero in on that particular zero no
pun intended right yeah so you should
get for that one negative four point
three seven comma zero that's the
location of that zero that x intercept
okay so let's take a look at number 45
so number 45 you're doing long division
now when you're dividing this polynomial
by X minus 2 you could do synthetic
division also I guess I'll show you both
ways so let's say you're dividing by X
minus 2 so this is X cubed minus 4 x
squared plus 7x minus 2 so you say how
many times does X go into X cubed well
it goes in there
x squared times then you take the x
squared and you distribute to both of
these so this is called you know
polynomial long division I've got videos
on the Semite Mario's math tutoring
channel then what you want to do is you
want to subtract now what a lot of
students do is they change the science
to the opposite so to make this negative
this pause and we'll add because the
tracking is like adding the opposite so
if you do that these are going to cancel
you get negative 2x squared plus 7x
minus 2 okay now how many times does X
go into negative 2 x squared well that's
going to be negative 2x times if we
distribute we get negative 2x squared
plus 4x and then what you want to do is
you want to subtract what a lot of 2
students do is they change the sign so
they opposite and they add so you can
see we keep trying to cancel out that
first term ok then how many times is X
go into 3x that's 3 times we distribute
we get 3x minus 6 change the science of
the opposite we add now what do you do
to remainder we put the remainder over
the divisor what we're dividing by and
that's your answer now you might be
asking Mario well how do we do this so
if we do synthetic division well let's
take a look so what you would do is you
would say 4 divided by X minus 2 you
just put positive 2 here okay and you
use the coefficients 1 negative 4 7 and
negative 2 now if you skip any of them
like if you skip from x cubed to ax you
skip over x squared you put a zero as a
placeholder but what you do is you bring
down that first term you multiply in the
diagonal and you add straight down and
then you multiply in the diagonal and
you add straight down and you multiply
in the diagonal and you add straight
down this last number is a remainder so
we started off with X cubed this goes
down by one degree so we get one x
squared minus two x plus three plus four
over our divisor X minus two and you can
see they match this is a little bit
quicker but this only works if you're
dividing by a linear factor and so if
it's like X plus two this would be a
negative two if it's X minus two it's
positive to that sign changes to the
opposite so we've got long division
synthetic division
number 46 it says list all possible
rational zeros of this function now
remember rational means ratio like a
fraction so nice it's called the P over
Q method or the zero root theorem the
rational root theorem something like
that but basically you take all factors
of the constant over all the factors of
the leading coefficient so all the
factors of 5 would be plus or minus 1
plus or minus 5 all over the factors of
leading coefficient which are plus or
minus 1 plus or minus 3 so it can be any
combination of the numerator divided by
the denominator so we could say 1 over 1
which would be plus or minus 1 1 over 3
that's plus or minus 1/3 5 over 1 which
is plus or minus 5 or plus or minus 5/3
and you can put those in order from
lowest to highest but those are the
possible rational zeros what that means
is that's where it crosses the x-axis
this graph if you were to graph it those
are the possible ones now for number 47
they give us two functions f of X equals
x squared minus 1 G of x equals 3x and
it says find f of G of X G of f of X
this is called the composition of
functions and letter C we're dividing
two functions we're stating the domain
so let's see if we can tackle this
problem what I would do for this form
with the composition of functions is I
would take this in steps so G of x
equals 3x I'm gonna replace G of X with
3x now the wave functions works is
whatever is in the parentheses goes in
for the X on the right so I'm gonna put
3x this whole thing in place of where X
was right so it's a substitution then if
we simplify we get 9x squared minus 1
now this one is the reverse we have G of
f of X so again I would like to take it
in steps I'm going to take f of X which
is x squared minus 1 I'm replacing f of
X with what it equals x squared minus 1
and remember whatever is in the
parentheses in here for our G function
goes in for X on the right side in place
of X so I'm going to put x squared minus
1 in place of X so it's like a double
substitution you can think of it as then
if I distribute and simplify I'm going
to get 3x squared minus 3 ok now a
letter C says G of X divided by f of X
so here what we have is 3 x over x
squared minus 1 now that's our answer
but it says state the domain now when we
look at fractions we can never have a
denominator be 0 because that's
undefined so what I would do is I would
set that denominator equal to 0 take the
square root of both sides remember you
get two answers so that means that
cannot equal plus or minus one so the
domain would be all real numbers except
for positive one or negative one okay
question number 48 it says find an
equation of the inverse of f of X equals
2x plus 5 so when you find the equation
of an inverse the key is to think of f
of X is y and what you do with the
inverse is you switch the X and the y
and you solve for the new Y so you
switch the X and the y solve for the new
Y so we have x equals 2y plus 5 what I'm
going to do is I try to get Y by itself
so I'm going to subtract 5 from both
sides I'm gonna divide everything by 2
so if I write that over here we've got y
equals 1/2 X minus 5 halves or instead
of Y you can use the inverse notation
the function inverse notation so 1/2 X
minus 5 halves so that's how you write
the inverse of a function
now number 49 is to solve this radical
equation okay so what we want to do is
we want to get rid of the square root by
getting it by itself on one side okay
and then square both sides so if I do
that I get x squared minus 4x plus 4
equals 2x minus 1 because the square and
the square root cancel then what we want
to do is we want to get everything on
one side of the equation set it equal to
0 then if you can factor it and set the
factors to 0 or do the quadratic formula
so all I'm doing is factoring it if I
set the factors equal to 0 I get 5 or
positive 1 now the bad thing about
solving radical equations is that you
want to go back to that original
equation okay the very starting of
equation before we square both sides and
you want to put these values in to see
if it makes it true if it doesn't you
get a false answer that's called an
extraneous root and you cross that one
out so what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
put a 5 in here 5 minus 2 is 3 2 times 5
is 10 minus 1 is 9 square root of 9 is 3
so that one actually checks out 5 is
good if we put 1 in here one minus 2 is
negative 1 2 times 1 is 2 minus 1
squared of 1 is 1 negative 1 does not
equal 1 therefore this is extraneous
crossing out fives our good answer there
ok number 50 it says evaluate now
remember what it says evaluate that
means find the value and what they're
testing us on here are rational
exponents or what could be called
fractional exponents ratio means like a
ratio of an integer divided by an
integer now remember when you have a
negative exponent that
says to take the reciprocal or move it
to the other side of the fraction bar
the denominator is the root the
numerator is the power so what we're
really looking at here is the fourth
root of 16 cubed like that so what
number times itself four times is 16
that's 2 2 cubed is 8 so this comes out
to 1/8 the other way to do this is to
take the fourth root of 16 - 2 cubed is
8 and at the very end take the
reciprocal so the negative means to take
the reciprocal here are the 3 8 the
denominator that's the roots we're
seeing what's the cube root of 27 and
then the numerator the 2 that's the
power we want to square ok raise that to
the second power so cube root of 27 is 3
3 squared is 9 and that's our answer
there number 51 says simplify assume all
variables are positive they're asking us
to simplify this 4th root of this
quantity here so one way to do this is
to break this down using prime
factorization tree 32 is actually five
twos multiplied together ok and X to the
eighth is eight X's multiplied together
Y to the ninth is nine Y's and so on but
when you're taking a fourth root you're
looking for groups of four of the same
number so we've got a group of four
there that's 16 the fourth root of 16 is
2 but we have a 2 left over that stays
underneath the radical there okay X to
the 8th we would have two groups so
that's going to be x squared the Y to
the 9th we have also two groups but one
left over 4 goes into 9 twice remainder
1 and then 4 goes into 18 let's see
that's going to be 4 times that's 16
remainder 2 so that's our way of
simplifying so the easy way I like to do
it is just see how many for how many
times 4 goes into that exponent and
whatever is left over that stays
underneath the radical whatever however
many times it goes in evenly that's what
comes out on the outside that many
number 52 is to solve this equation here
so what we want to do is want to work
from the outside in towards the X so
instead of multiplying by 2/3 I'm going
to multiply by the reciprocal 3 halves
that way that cancels and just gives us
X to the fifth 18 divided by 2 is 9 9
times 3 is 27 now all we have to do is
just take the fifth root ok the fifth
root of 27 like that or you can raise it
to the 1/5 power because the
goal one-fifth is the same as taking the
fifth route so let's go ahead and go to
the calculator on that one 27 to the 1/5
power or the fifth root 1.93
approximately is what you get which you
should get so if you're enjoying this
video and you like my teaching style and
you're preparing for the AC T or the SAT
the math section check out my huge AC T
math review video course for my huge SAT
math review video course there's a
teaching segment we do example problems
together
there's formulas there's tips and
techniques that you can use to boost
your score on those tests there's three
free previews check that out see if it's
something you're interested in a lot of
students have taken those courses and
benefited and reported back that they
improve their scores so I hope you will
also take advantage of that but let's
continue with this video here it says if
a classic-car appreciates that 10% per
year and is currently $23,000 in how
many years will it be worth $40,000 so
the equation we're looking at here is a
equals P one plus R to the T the P is
the principal or the starting amount in
this case the car is worth 23,000 it's
going up that's why we're we have the
plus if it was going down would be minus
the rate is 10% which is 0.1 zero and
then the T is the time well I don't know
when it's going to be worth 40,000 okay
so here's the thing we want to solve for
T when that variable is in the exponent
position like that that usually means
we're gonna have to take the log okay so
what we're going to do is we're gonna
work from the outside in towards that T
so I'm going to divide both sides by
23,000 so if I do that I get 40 over 23
equals I'm going to combine these
together that's one point one zero to
the T and then what I'm going to do is
I'm going to just take the natural log
of both sides okay as long as you do the
same thing to both sides of the equation
it keeps it balanced and then what I'm
going to do is I'm going to bring that T
down in front that's one of the
properties of logs that's called the
power rule so that's going to give you T
times the natural log of 1.10 and then
now what I'm going to do then is I'm
going to divide both sides by the
natural log of 1.10 to get the T by
itself so divided by natural log of 1.10
now let's go to the calculator and see
what that comes out to
so let's see we've got natural log of 40
divided by twenty three all divided by
the natural log of one point one zero
and that comes out to five point eight
years so that's what we're looking at
that's when it'll be worth forty
thousand five point eight years remember
you want to put your units with a story
problem number fifty-four it says
rewrite in exponential form this is the
logarithmic form and the key here in my
opinion easy way to do this says think
about logs and exponential functions as
inverse inverses of one another just
like squaring square rooting multiplying
dividing adding subtracting like that so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
raise both sides I'm going to
exponentiate both sides using base for
this is log base four I'm going to
exponentiate with base four now what we
have is in exponential form so we've got
four to the negative 2 equals 1/16 which
we know is true because 4 squared is 16
in the negative we just take the
reciprocal to get 1 over 16 55 is almost
the exact same thing except where it
says rewrite in logarithmic form what I
would do in a problem like this is I
would take the log base 3 of both sides
because these are inverses of each other
so now you get log base 3 of 243 equals
5 so that's the key to be able to switch
back and forth pitch in logarithmic form
an exponential form now this one says
evaluate Part A and Part B now a little
technique is if it doesn't say equal to
X I would set it equal to some variable
make it into an equation and then what
we'll do is we'll exponentiate both
sides you want these bases to be the
same I'm raising both sides or
exponentiating both sides using base 8
so we have 2 equals 8 to the X well
remember 8 is actually 2 cubed right 2
is like 2 to the first power to a power
we multiply so we get 2 to the 3x equals
2 to the first if the bases are the same
that means we can set the powers equal
that's called one-to-one property of
exponents so divide both sides by 3 and
you can see that x equals 1/3 for this
one I'm going to exponentiate or raise
both sizing base five
so exponentiating and taking a larger
than those are inverses of each other 5
to what power is 1 well you can see
anything to the 0 power is 1 so in this
case is just going to come out to 0
number 57 says find the domain and the
range well here's the thing our basic
log graph looks like this
okay it gets closer and closer to the
y-axis okay but what does the minus four
do to the graph it has the opposite
effect it actually shifts it right 4 1 2
3 4 so now our graphs going to look
something like this okay it's shifting
it right 4 so you can see the domain is
going to be X is greater than 4 but not
equal to greater than 4 because this is
the asymptote it can't equal 4 and then
the range you can see that this goes
down to negative infinity grad G goes up
to positive infinity so the range is
going to be all real numbers for the
range so I'll just say domain and range
okay question number 58 says expand now
I have a whole video talking about
everything you need to know about logs
you might want to check that video out
but basically what we have here is we've
got natural log of 3x squared minus
natural log of 4 y cubed now when you're
multiplying you add so I could write
this as natural log of 3 plus natural
log of x squared minus natural log of 4
plus natural log of Y cubed okay I put
that in parentheses because this whole
thing is being subtracted then what we
do is we bring down the powers in front
of the logs and then what I would also
distribute that negative through so the
final answer should look something like
this natural log of 3 plus 2 natural log
of X minus natural log of 4 minus 3
natural log of Y so that's fully
expanded now number 59 says condensed so
we're going the opposite direction so I
would bring their powers the
coefficients up as powers first so this
would be log of 7 minus log of x cubed
minus log of Y to the fourth now
anything that you're subtracting is
going to go into the Dom you are going
to be dividing so this is really like
log of 7 divided by X cubed Y to the
fourth like that okay number 60 says
evaluate now this is a good opportunity
to show you the change of base formula
what you do is you pick a new base okay
in this case I'm picking base E and what
you do is you could pick a log base any
base but the 50 goes in the numerator
and the base 5 goes in the denominator
and so in this case I just pick natural
log but it'd be natural 250 divided by
natural log of 5 okay number 61 and you
would simplify so let's see what that
one comes out to so we've got
natural log of 50 divided by natural log
of 5 and by the way that's not the same
as natural log of 10 that's sometimes
students make that mistake so you should
get to point 4 3 now some calculators
have the ability to change the base but
in this case we're just using the change
of base formula because some calculators
don't have that function so number 61
says e to the x equals 1/4 to the 2x
minus 5 now one way to approach this
problem is to use logs but what we're
going to do here is we're going to get
the bases to be the same so 8 cubed is
really like I'm sorry 8 is like 2 cubed
right and 1/4 is really like 2 to the
negative 2 but what do you do when you
have a power to a power you multiply
right so basically what we have is we
have 2 to the 3x power equals 2 to the
negative 4x plus 10 okay so now that we
have the same base we can use the
one-to-one property for exponents which
means if you have the same base you set
the power is equal to one another so I'm
just going to set those exponents equal
so that's negative 4x plus 10 I'm going
to add the 4x to both sides and divide
everything by 7 so we get x equals 10
sevenths you can put it back in and
verify that the left side and the right
side match okay continuing on we're
solving for x in this equation but this
is a log equation this is actually the
one-to-one property for logs so if you
have the same base you just set the
arguments equal to 1 each one another
okay and if I subtract the 3x from both
sides I get negative x equals negative 1
and divide both sides by negative 1 we
get x equals 1 one thing you want to be
careful of though when you're working
with logs is you cannot take the log of
zero or a negative number that's just
you know not possible it's not in the
restricted domain but let's go ahead and
put one back in we get natural log of 2
3 times 1 is 3 minus 1 is 2 natural log
of 2 equals natural log of 2 we're not
taking a log of 0 or a negative number
so we're okay this is a good answer
letter C though is a little bit more
challenging we've got let's see I meant
to write log base 4 on this one but we
want to do is we want to combine these
into one log first and then go ahead and
solve this logarithmic equation but
remember when you add what do you do to
the arguments you multiply okay so what
we're gonna do is are gonna multiply
those together we get x squared minus 9
and then instead of taking the log base
4 we want to exponentiate using the base
4 so I'm gonna raise both sides using
base 4 we get x squared minus 9
equals because these are inverses they
cancel each other out 16 if I add 9 to
both sides I get x squared equals 25
take the square root of both sides we
get x equals plus or minus 5 but
remember you want to go back and check
because we can't take the log of zero or
a negative number it has to be greater
than zero if we put negative five and
here we get log of negative eight that's
not that's not in our restricted domain
if we put five and that's two if we put
five in here that's eight that's okay so
in this case I'm going to erase the
negative it can only be positive five
okay last question you made it and
through this whole midterm review let's
see if we can simplify this we want to
get the variable by itself I like to
think about working from the outside in
so I'm going to do the opposite
operation I'm going to add 4 to both
sides that's 20 okay and now we've got 3
to the 2x minus 1 whenever the variable
is in the exponent position like that
unless the bases are the same where you
can use the one-to-one property of
exponents what you want to do is you
want to take the log of both sides so
I'm going to take the log base 3 of both
sides these are inverses they cancel you
get 2x minus 1 equals log base 3 of 20
and you're gonna add 1 to both sides
okay those cancel and your divide both
sides by 2 okay and you've got the X by
itself now all you have to do is
simplify and you got it so I'm gonna go
to the calculator and simplify but if
this asks for an exact answer that would
be your exact answer so let's see here
so we've got I'm using the change of
base formula cuz this is an older
calculator so I can get the same thing
that you guys are getting and then plus
1 and my other calculators in my car
right now so that comes out to 1.86
approximately and the nice thing is you
can always you know plug that in
approximately 1.8 6 + 2 X and just make
sure that you get about 16 so this has
been a whirlwind tour to help you
prepare for you know your midterm for
algebra 2 the first semester or if
you're just trying to brush up on your
algebra skills in general
I also remember I have that Algebra one
final exam review which goes over a lot
of algebra 1 concepts there is some
overlap between the two courses of
course especially at the beginning so
you might want to check that out but
again I hope you enjoyed it I hope you
benefited I hope you get a good grade on
your test subscribe to the channel give
this video a thumbs up if you enjoyed it
comment below let me know you know how
you did on the exam and I love to hear
from you and then also check out more
videos on my Mario's math tutor and
YouTube channel if there's anything
here that was unclear I've got videos on
all these different topics I look
forward to helping in the future videos
and I'll talk to you soon